In the name of the Father, and of the Son, and of the Holy Spirit, amen.
Dear Jesus, may I enter into the eternal divine order of God to place my absolute
nothingness in the heart of the Most Holy Trinity, to give to my God the joy of fulfilling the
purpose of my existence, by doing all the acts of my life through the immaculate heart of my
mother Mary and in the divine will of God. And in this same manner, may I live, pray, act, eat,
walk, sleep, and do everything. May my soul be devoid of any other longings, wants, or desires,
and may you, my beloved divine will, do with me whatever you want or desire.
All I ask is that you bind me to your most holy will so intimately that I may never swear from
carrying out what I know to be your good pleasure, and that I remain so docile to the movements of
your divine will that you never perceive even a breath of resistance in my soul to your requests
of me. Come divine will with all the angels and saints, especially my sweet mother Mary,
to touch my forehead, to imprint on it the Holy Spirit and infuse in me true light, so that I may
understand the truths and the good that are in these writings and prayers. Amen. We want to
begin this evening with August the 12th 1926. Okay, this is a wonderful passage in which the
Lord shows us the way to actually read him. Louisa said the privations of my sweet Jesus are getting
longer. Oh, how he makes me yearn for his return, how hours and days seem like centuries without him.
So that is a very, very, very deep relationship with God where you cannot tolerate his absence.
Most of us have no idea of this kind of depth of longing for God, and it's important to look
at it and realize that she's light years ahead of us. She said they not only are like centuries
without him, but centuries of night, not of days. So while I was anxiously waiting for him to return,
like a rising flash, he came out from within my interior because he's there all the time,
and the kingdom of God is within. That's Luke 1721. And Jesus said, my daughter, man was created
by God with three powers. This is an extremely important message. The memory, the intellect,
and the will, and this so that he might have the links of communications with the three divine persons,
three powers to reach the three divine persons. These were like paths along which to ascend to God.
So note that the intellect, the memory, and the will are paths to ascend to God. They're like doors
through which to enter. So you know where to go. You know what part of you to use.
They are like rooms in which to form the continuous dwelling. Now you note the continuous
dwelling. The Lord certainly is tired of being a guest. It's time that he actually took over,
and he ruled in his own dwelling. So that means that the kingdom of God actually is established
deep within each one of us. So it's a dwelling where the creature is for God, and God is for the
creature. To put that very simply, that's he and I. It's incredible. And when you reach this place
of the he and I, then everything is he. And the I part of it is simply to find out what he wants
and what he wants to do, and how I'm to cooperate with it, because he is Lord.
These are the royal paths for both of them. They're the most important pathways for both of them.
Notice for God as well as for the creature, because God made these paths into us.
These are the golden doors and gold represents Godhead. These are the golden doors which God
placed in the depths of the soul through which the supreme sovereignty of the divine majesty
might enter. Now look at the expression there. Anyone who has a Hail fellow well met approach to
God is not in this place, not at all. They're far far far away from this intimacy. And when you come
to this intimacy, you begin to realize with whom you have the intimacy. And you begin to grasp in
some small way who he is, the supreme sovereignty of the divine majesty. So if we're not growing
in humility, and if we're not growing in awe and wonder, then I don't think we're touching this.
You might have information in your head, but you're not actually touching it.
Because you'd have to grow in awe and wonder to the point of, I think, words would fail you.
This is the safe and unshakable room in which God was to have his celestial dwelling.
And Jesus told us in Matthew 6, that we were to enter into this dwelling, that we were to shut
the doors, the eyes major door, ears major door, mouth major door. We have to shut the doors
and go into that private place, that deep place within so that we can commune with the supreme
sovereignty of the divine majesty. And therefore, our prayer would have a huge levels of not only
awe and wonder, but extraordinary humility. Now, in order to be able to form its kingdom in the
inmost place in the soul, my will wants to find these three powers, which were given to the creature,
to raise her to the likeness of the Creator. This is what makes us different to all other creatures.
So he gave us these three powers in order with the Father, in order with the Son, and in order
with the Holy Spirit. So, intellect, Father, memory, Son, will Holy Spirit. This is all about love.
This is all about love. And it's about the pouring forth of love in infinite capacity
into this tiny, tiny ascetic that I can't actually receive it. But it's all about love,
and it's all about the transformation in love. There's a particular flight we're all going to take.
The ticket is booked. The pilot is in place. You're traveling first class. You're the only one on the
flight. No baggage alone. The only thing you can take with you on this final flight is love.
It's all about love. God's kingdom is all about love. God is love, the only ones who can come back
to him in that final dwelling place in his home in the celestial heavens is the ones who come back
in love with love through love. And so the three powers of the soul are extremely important.
There's different ways in which you can talk about intellect, memory, and will because they
correspond to the three persons as the Blessed Trinity. You can say life, light, and love.
It's one of the ways you can say it. You can say power, wisdom, and love. And they're not the only
ways either. I want you to think of a few of yourself, and you'll be amazed at how many ways
that you can actually talk about this reality. And when you say life and light, you're into all
this language that's in the divine will. We're talking about the life of light and the light of
life. And so it gives you back all the gospels again. And so the major thing that's got to happen
inside of us is that the intellect is put in order so that that pathway is clear. The memory is put
in order so that that pathway is clear and that the will is in order so that that pathway is clear.
So when the Lord comes to us, there's nothing actually blocking the way.
Jesus said, "My will would not go out of its dominions if these three powers of the soul were
not in order." Nothing unholy or unworthy can enter the presence of God. God wants to approach us
through the three powers of the soul so that its reigning would be happy. Now the prophet Amos
says, "How can two people walk together unless they are alike?" This likeness has to be there.
So that the reigning of the divine will would be happy and is so natural. In other words,
it's according to our creation because her three powers being in order with God, the creature would
have order within herself and outside of herself. That's an extremely important statement.
Everything within us has to come back into the divine order. We know that. But we don't seem to
realize that everything outside of us has got to go back into that divine order as well. That is all
our family relationships and our relationships with each other and our relationship with the church
and the world and everything. Everything's got to go back into God's order. That's how the kingdom
will conquer all the evil that's outside. Because her three powers being in order with God,
the creature would have order within herself and outside of herself and the kingdom of the divine
will and that of the creature would not be a divided kingdom. So it's a divided kingdom if
we are running our own lives independent of the divine will. That's a divided kingdom. And when
it comes into union and unity, then it's one kingdom. It's God reigning on the earth. It would
be a single one and therefore its dominion and regime would be one, which is what the Lord wants.
More so, since my will does not know how to reign where there is no order and harmony,
and this is something we have to look at in our own lives and in our relationships with others.
If the order and harmony is missing, then we do not have the way in which God can reign in us.
He will not reign in disharmony. Chaos and disharmony is a sign that Satan is around and certainly
a sign that the human will is around. So order and harmony are inseparable qualities and indispensable
properties with the divine persons. So if they are inseparable and they're indispensable,
then if the order and harmony is not there, we don't have that union. It's actually that simple.
He won't leave his dwelling to come to us unless this dwelling actually somehow is like him.
The two have to go together. And the soul can never be ordered and harmonized with
her Creator if she does not have her three powers open to receive from God his qualities ordered
and his properties harmonized. In such a way that finding the divine harmonies and the supreme
order of the divine will and of the human kingdom, my will may make them one and reign in it with
its full dominion. Let me give you that in simple English. If all of this happens he said I can
ratify the gift, can become permanent. Now notice he says that the three powers must be open to
receive from God. Now we might think we're actually open to receive from God, but many people are
blocked in personal opinions about things and personal prejudices about things. They're real blocks.
It can be a personal opinion or prejudice about a person or a thing or a way to do something. I've
always done it this way. That's a huge block. Say The Raise of List you tells us to go to God with
empty hands every single day. You don't lean on what you have achieved up to now. You don't lean
on your supposed virtues or holiness or whatever you think you have. You go to God with empty hands
and let him fill those empty hands every single day. And notice that God wants to give us his qualities,
love, joy, peace, patience, kindness, goodness, etc. His qualities. And he wants to give us
his properties harmonized so that there's going to be no war going on inside of us.
He doesn't want that. And if this is happening then he can ratify the gift that he said my will
can make them one and my will can reign with its full dominion. So that means that the gift is
ratified. My daughter Jesus said how much disorder reigns in the three powers of the human soul.
He knows one can say that they have shut the door in our face. Revelation 320 I'm knocking at the
door. If you open to me I will come in and I will sit beside you and I will stop with you.
Notice that means he's outside. And if the human will is reigning he is outside.
So one can say that they have shut the door in our face. They have barricaded the paths. That means
you do not surrender your intellect to God. You do not surrender your way of thinking. And we know
from Isaiah 55 verses 8 to 10 that God's way of thinking and ours is a different from the heavens
and the earth. It is a very wonderful thing if you turn to the Lord and begin to say to him
enable me to begin to think the way you think. Enable me to begin to see the way you see.
You have a very different way of dealing with things. He mightn't give it to you instantly.
Sometimes he does. Sometimes he doesn't. But beginning to think and to look and perceive and
understand the way he does. You're making huge strides. So many people have barricaded the path
to prevent our passing. Now the scriptures tell us that God is always passing by. Do you remember
the two men on the road to a mess in Luke 24? The Lord was passing by. They invited him in.
So we have to invite him into our intellect, our memory and our will. We have to invite him to take
over. And so they break the communications with us. If I insist on my own will in anything I'm
breaking that communication. While it was the greatest gift that we gave to man in creating him.
These three powers were to serve him to understand the one who had created him.
He's given us the ability to do it and to grow in his likeness. And his will being
transfused in that of his creator to give him the right to let the divine will reign. Now notice
the human will transfused in the divine. That's what we mean when we fuse ourselves with him.
Now make sure that when you say to the Lord I fuse myself in you or in your will that I'm not
just saying words. I'm saying I do actually hand it over. So if his will is transfused in that of
his creator then this gives him the right to let the divine will reign. So our wills really have to
be handed over permanently. This is why the supreme volition cannot reign in the soul. If these three
powers the intellect the memory and the will do not hold hands in order to return to the purpose
for which God created man. Therefore pray that these three powers may return to the order and
the harmony of their creator so that my supreme will may reign with his full triumph. Major stuff
there in terms of growth. So let's go on to August the 14th where Louisa is suffering because of
the publication of her works. My poor heart swims in the sea of the bitterness of the privations
of my sweet Jesus. If he comes at all he's like a flash that escapes and in that light of the flash
I see the poor world. I see its grave evils. I see the bonds among nations which are binding
themselves to one another in order to start wars and revolutions and by doing this they draw the
chastisements of heaven but so grave as to destroy entire cities and peoples. Now first of all Amos
three seven the Lord never does anything without letting the prophets know ahead of time and this
is 1926 and by the time the Second World War came he saw the blitz bombing of cities in Germany
and you saw the frightening obliteration of Hiroshima and Nagasaki with an atom bomb. She saw clearly
ahead of time and so she lamented how great is the human blindness but as the flash of his beloved
presence ends I remain in the dark more than before with the thought of my poor brothers
scattered in the heart exile of life. So he lets you see that then withdraws his visible presence
from her so that she has plenty to offer to him to do something about the souls who are going to
suffer in all of these cities where the trouble will be. But this is not enough to fill my poor
heart with intense vision is something else added to suffocate my poor existence with those roaring
waves that overwhelm my poor soul. Notice the language she's really suffering and that is the
news of the upcoming printing of the writings on the Most Holy Will of God since our Mount Senior
Archbishop had given his approval. Now there you have Mount Senior Archbishop in earlier volumes
you simply had Mount Senior and I said this means the bishop so here you have the proof. The bishop
so had given his approval placing the imprimatur himself. Some people ask the question do these
writings have the imprimatur here you have it being told to you but this was nothing. The most
fatal blow to my poor soul had been the news that they were going to put out not only what
regarded the divine will because after so much insistence from our Lord and the superiors I had
convinced myself that the glory of God required this and miserable and little as I am it's not
for me to oppose what blessed Jesus wants. But they were going to put out for printing also
the order that Jesus has kept with me and everything he has told me also about other virtues and
circumstances and this was too painful for me and I spoke out my reasons over and over again
that this shouldn't be done. So Louisa thinks that the knowledge of the divine will can be sent out
theoretically and Jesus says no way they have to see it working in you they have to see the way
you received it they have to see the way you journeyed along this long journey to reach this
absolutely extraordinary place. If they see this journey they can take it. We don't take things
purely intellectually very well because somebody needs to give you what I call a how to lesson how
do I take it out of the intellect and put it into reality and so all of that is in these writings
and that's why the Lord insisted. Then while I was so oppressed by sweet Jesus moving in my interior
as though feeling the weight of my oppression because they are one that's me in these arms
and shaking me up I love that told me my daughter what's the matter what's the matter be cheered I
do not want you so oppressed instead of thanking me you oppress yourself you must know that
so that my supreme will might be known I had to prepare things I had to dispose means I love
this I had to overwhelm the Archbishop I had to overwhelm the Archbishop with those acts of absolute
dominion of my will in other words the Lord had to be really strong with the Archbishop
which man cannot resist I had to make one of my great prejudice he said do you think it's easy
to obtain approval from a bishop now we say that to each other but this is the Lord saying it to
Louisa I find this absolutely astonishing how hard it is he said how many quibbles and how many
difficulties they produce and if they approve at all it is with many restrictions almost removing
the most beautiful shades the most striking colors from all that my goodness has revealed
with so much love don't you see then that the triumph of my will in the approval of the Archbishop
and therefore my great glory and the great necessity that the knowledge about the supreme will become
known and like beneficial Jew dampened the order of passions he says don't you realize this is all
essential and so what Jesus is saying is I'm doing all the work to get this stuff out and you're
doing all the complaining I mean give us a break like that's fascinating that is absolutely fascinating
that he not only has to work with the Archbishop to make him come around and work with the priests
to get them to accept he's to work with Louisa together to accept the way he wants to do it because
God's way of thinking is as different from our way of thinking as the heavens are from the earth
and this is absolute proof of it like a rising sun Jesus said my will dispels
the darkness of the human will so if the human will is to be dealt with so that the divine will
can reign somebody has to tell them about it he said my will dispels the darkness of the human
will and removes the torquer which almost all creatures have this is the lack of spiritual energy
the inability to deal with it even read the material and take it on board give time to it
this virtual torpor is there with almost everybody on the planet and he said it's only my will that
can dispel that so as we expose people to these writings and getting them reading their eyes
are opened and they begin to understand however little they understand at the beginning it doesn't
matter if they understand only a small amount it gets them on the road and it removes the torpor
that almost all creatures have in doing good because the life of my will is missing notice the life
the source of energy the source of grace my manifestations about the divine will will be like
the bam which will heal the wounds produced by the human will and i think everyone who comes to
these writings and is exposed to them in any way can testify to the calming of the soul when you
realize that you can go to the lord and you can cooperate with him and you can let him work
prejudice in your life those who will have the privilege of knowing these writings will feel
a new life of light grace and strength flow into them and in the hurricane that's coming upon us
on the earth you're going to need light and grace and strength to deal with it and people around you
will turn to you because they will see that you are strong and calm and trusting in god
not only this but in understanding the great evil of their own will they will abhor it and
they will shake themselves from the yoke this very hard yoke of the human will to place themselves
under the gentle dominion of mine matthew 1128 take my yoke upon you and learn of me for
i am meek and humble of heart and the yoke is not difficult it's the yoke of divine love that we
have to drown our own selfishness and our own self-interest so that divine love can actually
be born in us and the only bit that's difficult is actually deciding to let that human will go
and to let that human love and all the complications of human passions let them go and let the divine
love take over so that we begin to see with those divine eyes we see people in a completely different
light and we relate to people in their own shoes not because i have any connection with them or that
they are useful to me or anything like that or even that they need me that i can actually deal with
them in a very wonderful free way the old word for that is detachment the old traditional word is
detachment that you will allow people to be in their own shoes and you will allow god to use you
to be a source of life for them regardless of whether there's any benefit to you or not
so you have to throw off the very hard yoke of the human will and take on the very gentle and
wonderful yoke of divine love uh you do not know or see what i know and see jesus says and he's
talking about the whole human race so let me do it and do not repress yourself rather you yourself
should have urged and pushed the one whom i have disposed with so much love shake on this commitment
you should have told me to hurry up i do see we the one to stop at all it's extraordinary how
differently we think from the lord even at her stage extraordinary state and so the exposure to
the writings and the study of the writings is absolutely essential we have to get as many people
as possible exposed to them my daughter the kingdom of my will is unshakable and in this knowledge
about it i have placed so much light grace and attraction as to render it victorious that means
who we come to these writings this light and grace is there for us and as we read it we should ask
the lord to enable us to understand it at a deeper level than we understood it before
because the way people read nowadays is what i call surf writing on the sea they get a surface
experience and they don't let the lord bring them down to experience the sea at the deeper levels
so deep sea diving is what is needed to really take the treasures out of this writing
so the kingdom of my will is unshakable and in this knowledge about it i have placed so much
light grace and attraction as to render it victorious in such a way that as they become known they will
wage a sweet battle against the human will and creatures will be conquered i love the will be
this knowledge will be an immensely high and strong wall more than the terrestrial eden
which will prevent the enemy from entering in order to molest those who conquered by it will
pass to live in the kingdom of my will i read that quickly we've got to revisit it what jesus
saying is as you get into the divine will as you expose yourself to the revelations of the divine
will as you try and grasp more and more he says that the wall of protection that he puts around you
is much higher than that was in the garden of eden so that the enemy won't be able to come in
and steal this from you because he so badly wants people living the divine will that he takes great
care of anybody who will actually do it it's wonderful let me read it for you again so as we
expose ourselves to this wonderful material the revelations wage a sweet battle against the human
will because the more you read about the dangers of the human will you couldn't possibly be clinging
to it you'd have to let go of the writings or let go of the the will and this knowledge will be
an immensely high and strong wall that's why we've got to remain studying there's no point in which
we can stop studying these writings because we have to have this knowledge continuously building
this protective wall around our soul and as this immensely high and strong wall is there
this will prevent the enemy from entering in order to molest those who conquered by the divine will
will pass to live in the kingdom of my will now those of you who have done the book of revelation
with me should recognize in this sentence that i've gone over twice the high walls of the new
Jerusalem very high walls of protection for those who live in the new Jerusalem because those living
in the new Jerusalem are living in the divine will beautiful just to see the connection between
the two so let's go on to august the 18th 1926 and we're still dealing with printing the writings
so louisa said while i was praying i found myself outside of myself and at the same time i saw the
reverend father who must occupy himself with the printing of the writings on the most holy will of
god our lord was near him he's near everybody dealing with these writings taking all the knowledge
and the effects and the values he has manifested about the supreme will which had changed into threads
of light now look what happens when you try and take this material and take it into yourself he had
changed them into threads of light and impressing them on this priest's intelligence now you know
what prayer to say when you come to reading this lord take this material turn it into threads of
light and impress it into my intelligence so that i can take it and in such a way as to form a crown
of light around his head and while doing this he said to him my son the task i have given you is
great and therefore it's necessary that i give you much light in order to make you understand
with clarity what i have revealed now all of you who are teaching others that's exactly what the
lord wants to give you the more you want to share with other people this wonderful material the more
he will give you clarity and understanding why because he wants to give life to the students that
you're actually dealing with and he's the one who's in charge of the whole thing and over and above
your iq and your educational experience or anything else that you might think is a drawback he wants
this material to get through to give life to those people you're sharing with you give it here it's
wonderful in fact he said they will produce their effects according to the clarity with which they
have been exposed oh dear the effects that will come to others through these writings is in proportion
to the clarity with which it is actually revealed so we have to be very careful when we're teaching
that we are allowing consciously allowing that light to come into us so that we'll go out to others
and that there's no quibbling about what we say if there's something you don't understand just say
i don't understand it and move on that's much more honest than trying to say something you don't
understand and let the enemy come in and darken that wonderful gem in fact these writings will
produce their effects according to the clarity with which they are exposed even though they are most
clear in themselves but that doesn't mean our intellect and our memory and our will are in order
so to the point at which they are not back in the divine order then there's things we don't say
don't hear and don't understand indeed that which regards my will is light
that descends from heaven which does not confuse and dazzle the sight of the intelligence it doesn't
do that but it has the power the word virtue is given wrong there but it has the power of strengthening
and enlightening the human intellect so as to be understood and loved this is very important for
all of us who are sharing this with anybody else because all we have to do is ask and open our own
intellect memory and will to the lord and let that light come into us and the more it comes into us
the more we will understand and you might even find as i think a lot of teachers find that you
will say something in explanation and wonder yourself where it came from because it's coming
directly from the one who is speaking through you so doesn't dazzle and it doesn't confuse now if
you're dealing with anything that Satan can get in on oh yes it's very complicated and you have to be
super intelligent to try and grasp it at all and there's all kinds of stuff and you just say no
that's not for me it's that's for super people but when the lord is sharing something it comes as
clear as a ray of light it has the power of strengthening and enlightening the human
intellect so as to be understood and loved and it has the power of casting into the depth of the soul
the source of her origin and you know sometimes this happens even as you're speaking it
even as you're sharing it with others you're opening up and you're letting this actually
happen and the true purpose for which man was creative the order between the creator and the
creature so this has got to happen as we are reading it we're praying it sharing it with others
and each one of my sayings each one of my manifestations each knowledge about my supreme will
all these are as many strokes of the brush to make the soul return to the likeness of our creator
every single thing and so there you have Ephesians 210 we are God's work of art created in Christ
Jesus everything I have said about my will watch this now this is important everything I've said
about my will he said is nothing other than preparing the way forming the army gathering the chosen
people underline preparing the royal palace disposing the ground on which the kingdom of my will
must be formed and so rule and dominate let me give you that an ordinary language he's saying
everything that I do in the divine will is preparing that new Jerusalem is preparing that new era
I am calling a people who will be my chosen people and I am building them up and I'm making it possible
for them to live there if they're at this moment living in their human will they're now ready for
the new Jerusalem they're now ready for the new era it's incredible now notice I'm gathering a
chosen people go back to the book of Exodus what did he do he gathered a chosen people
go back to the gospel what did he do he gathered a chosen people now we come to the era of sanctification
what is he doing gathering a chosen people did a huge number follow God in any of those stages
no not in the beginning and it's through this dedicated group of people who really will give
themselves to God that he achieves everything I always say that the angels come down from heaven
to us first that is the revelation comes down from heaven and then we have to become the terrestrial
angels taking it out to everybody else so everything I have said about my will is nothing other than
preparing the way forming the army and gathering the chosen people preparing the royal palace disposing
the ground on which the kingdom of my will must be formed and so rule and dominate
getting the new Jerusalem ready therefore the task that I am entrusting to you is great I will guide
you that is due to around me 30 to 11 I think this are 12 the Lord alone was his guide I will be
near you anything to do with his divine will and he's around he's close so that everything may be
done according to my will and what is he trying to do well I've said it but he's going to give it
here now he wants to form a church of light in other words every member will be like this
initially this starts with a small group but what he's aiming at is what I call the church rising
from the dead and living at its highest level of being so after this Jesus blessed that's the
priest who has to look after these writings and came to my little soul resuming his speaking and
he said my daughter how much I care about my will how I love how I yearn that it become known my interest
is so great now listen very very carefully my interest in the divine will is so great that I am
disposed to give any grace to whom ever wants to occupy himself to make it known so if you're
prepared to share this material he wants that so badly he will give you any grace that's needed
any grace he himself put no limit on it I am disposed to give any grace to whomever notice
it doesn't say male female old young educated or otherwise he doesn't say that he puts no limits
on it to whomever wants to occupy himself in making the divine well known oh how I wish that they would
hurry because I see that all my rights will be given back to me the order between god and the
creature will be reestablished I will no longer give my gifts to the human generations halved
but as a whole nor will I ever again receive from them things that are incomplete
but whole am I daughter being able to give and wanting to give and finding no one to whom to give
is always a pain and a weight with no hope of relief if you knew how much they watch this now
if you knew with how much jealousy of love I stay around the soul when I see her disposed to do her
acts in my will now if you want me to give you that nornery language when you want to pray in the
divine will you are overshadowed by his presence to use the language of the Old Testament the shekinah
the glory is with you and that is the ultimate in this life that you would have the glory in this life
if you knew with how much jealousy of love I stay around the soul when I see her disposed to do her
acts in my will before she begins her act I make the light and the power of my will flow into it
so that her act may take its origin from the power my will contains it can't be a divine act
unless it comes from a divine source and as she keeps forming it the divine light and the power
invested and carry it out notice he's doing all the work as she completes her act the light is sealed
over it and gives it the form of a divine act people nowadays who know we're expecting the anti-Christ
show his ugly face are all worried about the mark of the beast they're not looking at this
wonderful ceiling that the Lord gives to every divine act that we do oh how my supreme goodness
delights in seeing that the creature possesses this divine act little tiny creatures possessing
this divine act to these acts my eternal love never says enough it gives and gives and always
gives because with these divine acts formed by the creature in my will my love cannot limit itself
since they are divine therefore do not worry about any person you're praying for just put them into
that divine abundance and thank him in the divine will my love cannot limit itself since they are
divine it must repay them with infinite love and without limits I mean even one line of this sin
of descent into ecstasy don't you yourself see and feel with how much love I guide you
Jesus said to Louisa I accompany you and many times I reach the point of doing what you're doing
together with you he actually prays with you he's doing all the work anyway and this in order to
give to your acts a divine value how happy I am in seeing that by virtue of my will your acts are
divine but it's by virtue of his will everything is through him with him and in him and they're
similar to mine there's no more distance between your little love and mine between your adoration
and mine between your prayers and mine try and take that on board it's incredible
your little love your adoration and your prayers are invested by the light of the eternal volition
and they lose their finiteness and their human appearances and they acquire the infinite and
the divine substance and transforming all together the working of God and the soul my will makes them
one he does the transforming turns my nothing into this therefore be attentive and let your flight
always be continuous so he goes on talking about acts in the divine will after this my beloved
Jesus came back and made himself seen all worried suffering and as though restless because of the
great offenses of creatures I wanted to calm him and give him rest and this bit of revelation for
you so he's suffering I want to calm him what do I do. Louisa said I wanted to calm him and give him
rest but I couldn't manage then the thought came to me of doing my usual acts in the supreme fiat
and as I was doing this Jesus would calm down and take rest so what she's getting here is an
illustration of what has just been taught that if you know the greatness of a divine act and you want
to console the Lord in Gethsemane or in any part of his suffering or the way he's suffering in the
torture in the world today then you know that the way to do it is by doing the divine act so he said
to me my daughter the acts in my will are more than solar rays which are such that if one wants to
look at them one sight is eclipsed by the light in such a way that one can neither look nor distinguish
anything anymore in other words we have no comprehension of the greatness of a divine act
if the light of the sun has so much power much more to the act on in my will the light of my will
has the power to eat clips and take evil away from creatures there's the answer to an awful lot
of your worries many of you are worried about your children or your grandchildren or whoever it is
there's your answer the light of my will has the power to eat clips and take evil away from creatures
that they may not do worse things and with the power of its light it prevents the offenses from
reaching me isn't that important somebody who's not yet ready to come to the Lord someone who's not
ready to repent and turn back to God that you can prevent the offenses actually reaching him
so that grace will still go to them and just as the light of the sun because it contains the
simile of the eternal son of the supreme fiat contains all colors and from them derive innumerable
facts which unleash countless goods for the human generations while one seems to see nothing but
radiant and white light contains everything it is the same for the eternal son of my will
while it is the light of my will alone inside of it there are as though many colors all the divine
similes enclosed which contain infinite effects and unleash fountains of love and goodness and mercy
and power and knowledge in some all of the divine qualities therefore the working of my will contains
such power and harmony as to favor the rest of your beloved Jesus so there you have the enormity
of the grace that's actually involved in doing your divine acts i'm going to leave it there because
the next message is too long to start at this time the hour is almost up and so we'll leave it there
for this week and i'll see you next week you have an awful lot of treasure to take on board